Last year, the New York Times published
the 1619 Project,
an immensely ambitious, influential and
controversial reframing of American history.
The project's creator, Nikole Hannah-Jones,
who won a Pulitzer Prize for her work
argued that the U.S. Constitution was
a decidedly undemocratic document,
and that anti-black racism runs
in the very DNA of this country.
Our country says that we were
founded to be a democracy,
but we were actually founded as a slavocracy.
This interpretation of the American founding
has been the subject of a heated debate.
The 1619 Project has also been adapted
into a high school curriculum that attempts
to reframe U.S. history by
marking the year when the
first enslaved Africans arrived on Virginia soil
as our nation's foundational date.
After the 1619 Project was
attacked by five eminent historians,
the Projects Editor responded by reiterating
Hannah-Jones' view, that
advances for minority groups
have almost always come as result
of political and social struggles
in which African-Americans
have generally taken the lead,
not as a working-out of the
immanent logic of the Constitution.
But this view of the Constituion and
the Declaration of Independence,
is at odds with that of Frederick Douglass,
the escaped slave, abolitionist, author,
and towering figure in American history.
In his new book A Glorious Liberty:
Frederick Douglass and the Fight
for an Antislavery Constitution,
Reason Senior Editor Damon Root looks
at the arguments that took place
in the middle of the 19th century
over racism and America’s founding,
which are being replayed today.
If you look at what Frederick Douglass and
William Lloyd Garrison were fighting over
in 1840s and 1850s, you see what people are
fighting about right now, which was the founding.
Just a pro-slavery compact and
Douglass completely rejects that.
As a former slave, Douglass had no illusions
about racism, but his view of the constitution,
which he called a glorious liberty
document would put him at odds
with many of its contemporary critics.
Douglass' challenged really is that the
constitution and the Declaration of Independence
lay out these powerful principles,
but why don't we live up to them?
Clearly, the nation is not
living up to those principles.
Habeas corpus, due process of law,
the right to keep and bear arms.
Any of those things if sort of
fully enforced, slavery can't stand.
And he would point that out
again and again and again.
Root argues that Douglass was a classical
liberal,
who believed in the primacy of
individual rights and economic freedom.
One of his intellectual adversaries was the
slavery apologist George
Fitzhugh, Who's 1854 book,
Sociology For The South or The Failure of
Free Society, defended slavery by repudiating
the principles of liberalism.
He has this attack on John Locke, attack on Adam
Smith, attack on all these liberal principles,
and you see Frederick Douglass picking up
the banner of those principles and making
it a bedrock of his all-out war on slavery.
He talked about the powerful experience of
earning his first free dollar on the docks
in New Bedford, Massachusetts, when
he escapes and what that meant to him,
that he was now his own master, a tremendous
fact, he writes in one of his autobiographies.
It all comes back to this idea of self ownership.
In Locke's theory of self ownership, property
rights begins with the ownership in yourself
and everything flows out from that.
Unlike many of his contemporaries,
Douglass extended his beliefs in unalienable,
individual rights to women as well.
In 1848, he attended the Seneca Falls Convention
that launched the women's suffrage movement.
There are 100 people at the
Seneca falls convention.
He's one of 32 men, he's the only black person
there.
He takes the radical position
alongside Elizabeth Cady Stanton,
that women should have—not just a whole host of other legal privileges that they're denied at the time—
but women should have the right to vote.
Stanton said that was almosttoo radical for the convention, there were people who were against it.
They thought, "Oh, we can't go that far," and
Douglass was right there, shoulder
to shoulder with her on that issue.
Douglass would have a bitter falling out with
Elizabeth Cady Stanton and other suffragettes
after the Civil War, when only former
male slaves got the right to vote,
but he would reconcile with
them later in his life.
The last thing that Douglass does the day he
dies is he attends a womens rights meeting,
that's his last public act and he goes home
and dies of either a heart attack or a stroke.
He falls dead in his home.
So he goes out doing what he always
did, fighting for liberty and equality.
In a country that seems more divided along
racial and ethnic lines than it has been in decades,
Root says that Frederick Douglass'
belief in principles undergirding
the American founding have a lot to
teach us about how to build a society
based on mutual respect,
empathy, and individualism.
Douglass, he says, stressed that
rights for one are rights for all,
ending slavery was also something
that benefited the country as a whole,
because slavery is a pernicious institution,
it's economically crippling,
all these sorts of things.
A free labor system benefits whites and blacks,
to the extent that a civil rights cause looks like it just benefits one group,
in fact, the benefits are
far and wide to all involved.
That's certainly a lesson we
can continue to take today.
The nation's founding doesn't need to be dialed
back to 1619 to acknowledge the horrific legacy
of slavery and honor the major role played
by African-Americans in the nation's history
we would do well not only to remember the
example set by Frederick Douglass in his life,
but also to embrace his understanding of the
Constitution as a glorious liberty document,
whose ideals of freedom and equality
we must never stop fighting to realize.